final preparations before surgery dr.
Moo Khalid sawed marks the areas where
he plans to make incisions this patient
from Yemen is suffering pain from burn
scars left behind from a bomb attack the
plastic surgeons and orthopedic doctors
in their special clinic treat long-term
complications resulting from war
injuries
this patient has burn wounds on his arms
and back it's difficult for him to move
his arms I'll try to give him some
movement back for shadi it's all he can
hope for
I hope the operation will go well and
I'll be able to live a normal life again
but first of all dr. Mohammad and his
team have to deal with a wounded child
from Syria there's little prospect of
undergoing these highly specialized
operations whether patients come from
here surgery is free of charge we take
in patients from Yemen Iraq Syria and
sometimes Palestine in Libya they often
have severe war wounds which later
developed complications the surgeon is
confronted with the horrors of war in
the Middle East on a daily basis dr.
Mohammed comes from Iraq he's deeply
affected by the fate of his patients
I have to separate my emotions from my
work in order to help these people
we empathize with them outside of the
surgery room
they all have tragic stories imagine a
bomb or a fire suddenly turning a
perfectly healthy person into someone
with disabilities the young man from
Yemen is out of surgery most of the
patients have to undergo lengthy
rehabilitation therapy the clinic offers
this also but the waiting list is long
Moy Yat from Syria is learning to walk
again the 26 year old has already had
three operations and has been coming to
the rehabilitation clinic for seven
months listen Oh first I'm gonna do you
know I'm not thinking too much about
what comes after that I'm doing it bit
by bit
no yet needs a lot of willpower and
support from the therapists they also
offer their patients psychological
support the doctors also recognize the
need for psychological support in the
recovery from injury we're dealing with
two things we're not only aiming to heal
superficial wounds but also the wounds
on their soul
Shari's operation went well he can move
his arms better the doctors now have to
deal with their next patient the
conflicts in the region won't let them
rest